and finally new rules someone must tell
me why'd the people who wrapped
themselves in the flag are always the
ones most clueless about what it
represents like the way Trump turned a
respectful protest about police
brutality into a patriotism pissing
match the nerve of these young black men
kneeling while an American Idol
runner-up sings the bombs bursting in
air song how dare you exercise your
freedoms while we're honoring them
we will not stand for not standing Trump
literally said that soldiers have died
and we need to stand because they were
fighting for our national anthem for
[ __ ] sake no one ever died for the
anthem some have died trying to sing it
but Trump knew that for conservatives
the anthem is their senior prom theme
song it makes them all misty-eyed the
way I get when I hear the captain and
Tennille do that to me one more time
remember this guy John Boehner so
unpopular with his own Republicans they
booted him out of being Speaker but they
never criticized him for doing this
I poured my heart and soul into running
a small business it's provided for the
safety and security of the American
people
[Applause]
no sir whenever he'd cry like a little
[ __ ] because someone mentioned small
business or he saw a tiny American flag
in his club sandwich they all would
think that was great what is it with
these people always falling to pieces of
her flags and anthems and commercials
for pickup trucks and all these throat
catchers route 66 and porch swings
barber shops that still offer a shave
and cowboy hats unless you're a black
congresswoman
farms
old barns
pictures of wheat give them a hard-on
for the party that things of itself is
the tough guys they're so susceptible to
sentimentalism that's why they love the
paintings of Thomas Kinkade with his
vision of America as one big Hobbit
village of fairytale cottages and of
course Christmas
they are so head-over-heels Lady Gaga in
love with Christmas
they even imagined liberals have somehow
banned everyone from talking about it
until Trump got elected and now the bed
has been lifted we could say Merry
Christmas again they really believe this
[ __ ] it's like no one ever broke it to
them that the bearded guy who delivers
goodies isn't real
[Applause]
but nothing but nothing triggers that
soft mushy part of a right-winger more
than the military they love the military
the way eight-year-old girls love horses
wholly and completely with a slight
tinge of sexual frustration they get a
tingle in their taint when the Blue
Angels fly overhead they cry during the
president's Martian fighting speech in
Independence Day they see a guy in
uniform at the mall and say thank you
for your service even though the guy's
thinking I'm a security guard [ __ ]
last week in his heroic battle against a
grieving widow
Donald Trump sent general Kelly out to
talk to the media and offer us a lesson
about honor and when that honour lesson
included blatantly lying about
congresswoman Wilson general Kelley was
criticized which president Trump's
spokesperson said was highly
inappropriate that's right it is highly
inappropriate to ever question a general
which it is in North Korea but I thought
this was America
this impulse to tell people not to
protest against the police not to
question the generals this is not
American and that is the problem with
all the fetish patriotism it starts with
goosebumps but it ends with goose steps